vous avez une petite fille qui s'appelle
jeanne et donc on va faire l'interview
expliqué à ma fille
on a beau cheval pendant le tigre
[Applaudissements]
il ya beaucoup de belles affiches ce
soir
c'est votre petite fille qui parle à
travers moi ah bon maman maman pourquoi
personne m ben laden elle est très
fasciné par sa barbe ça par contre toi
ça les pattes mais c'est vrai qu'il a un
sourire assez doux - oui les enfants se
rendent pas compte peut-être qu'ils le
trouvent sympathique
oui sauf que ma fille pas vraiment parce
qu'en plus son papa est américain donc
donc voilà ça change je sais pas qui
c'est sans papa moi j'ai
alors toujours cette petite fille maman
maman pourquoi johnny il a une mercedes
et toi tu n'as pas
parce que je n'ai beaucoup moins j'ai
beaucoup moins d'argent que johnny est
que je n'ai pas le goût
j'ai pas un goût prononcé pour les
voitures et que j'ai un renault espace
et
fonder une franchement c'est un peu anti
c'est que si renault espace pour une
fille commenté très jolie est une très
jolie fille très jolie femme dans une
renault espace ça vous met pas en valeur
faut acheter une capacité de marque mais
il ya plein de voitures qui vous irait
mieux mais j'ai pas besoin de ça pour
mettre en valeur
m
témoin bien alors maman maman de deux
petites filles comment on fait les bébés
eh ben on met la petite graine
j'aime beaucoup le jardinage
et maman ça veut dire quoi annie aime
les sucettes à l'anis
j'ai passé les gosses
non moi je répondrai tout simplement que
c'est très très bon lait ce satané voilà
une caution
voilà encore une question de la petite
jeanne dit maman c'est quoi la question
qui n'a pas de réponse
peut-être celle de thierry ardisson
au kiel et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux